hey guys dr. Berg here in this video
we're gonna talk about the perfect
exercise now what is the perfect
exercise it really is based on your body
so you have people that are completely
out of shape completely burnt out and
any of those people that are really top
athletes so we're gonna just teach you
the elements so you can adapt them to
your workout it really exercises
composed of three simple variables we
have the time of exercise we have the
intensity and then we have the recovery
and then you also can have frequency and
how many times you do it but that's the
simplicity of a workout now the question
is if you're going for toning or you're
going for fat-burning
there's different things that you can go
for like for example if you're going for
toning you're going to be working in the
body part a little differently what I'm
going to talk about is mainly overall
fitness and fat burning okay it's how to
maximize that so the first thing to know
is that the time of exercise is really
not something that increases growth
hormone which is the main fat burning
hormone so in fact the more you work out
the more you increase cortisol the more
you add stress to the body so these
people that are doing that let's say the
high-intensity long duration hour hour
and a half boot camp every single day
all they're doing is raising cortisol
they're not going to get fit they're not
going to lose weight so ideally to
trigger growth hormone you need shorter
time higher full-body intensity and lots
of recovery that would be the best
option now let's first talk about
intensity what kind of intensity do I
mean well anything that works your every
single muscle at one time that would be
the best thing like some people would do
some type of kickboxing aerobic type
workout where they're doing you know
lower body and upper body I like to do
deadlifts in fact that really helps my
back when I do that but doing a good
deadlift with great technique you can
get some serious intensity because
you're using every single muscle that
you have you can also do jump rope you
can do
like certain types of yoga is very very
high intensity you know to work every
single body so we want to do something
that spikes the pulse rate fast and
works all your body but we don't want to
do this for a long time but you want to
do it short now here's the here's the
rule of thumb the maximum time of
workout if you're doing interval
training which is short high-intensity
rest short intensity high rest would be
between 20 and 40 minutes any time you
have to go over 40 minutes what that
means is that you're going to diminish
your returns it would be much better
than increase the intensity so I like to
do short high-intensity rest but if
you're just starting out we're just
getting into it 20 minutes every other
day is fine so what I'm talking about is
let's say you're gonna do some type of
workout where you would do a high
intensity for 2 maybe 3 minutes maybe 1
to 3 minutes and then you would rest for
maybe 4 to 5 minutes versus if you're
doing like CrossFit which is way over
training for most people unless you're
18 years old
this whole thing with workout one minute
on one minute off does not work you're
not going to have enough recovery we
want that pulse rate to come all the way
down I also do biking so I'll sprint for
like one to two minutes really hard my
whole body and then I'll rest in Coast
for about 2 to 3 to 4 minutes and then
I'll do it again and I'll do that for 20
to 40 minutes every other day and the
off days I'll do walking so those are
just some rules of thumb because this
will increase growth hormone now the
other value variable is this recovery
right here all the benefit from the
exercise occurs in that second recovery
stage primarily when you're sleeping and
48 to 72 hours later that's where all
the good stuff happens because you this
is all just stress this is all just
rebuilding recovering fat burning and
that takes some time now with recovery
if you're doing high-intensity you have
to be really good shape to do that every
day you may be wanting to do that every
other day now there are some people that
I work with that have to recover a lot
longer so I might have them do a
high-intensity workout and then recover
for 4 to 5 days I had people that I
switched them from every other day to
once a week and man they start losing
weight like crazy so this is something
you want to test in your body to see if
you're not losing weight increase
recovery and see if that doesn't help
you versus sacrificing your sleep
getting up early at 4 o'clock in the
morning to get that workout it's much
better to get to sleep than it is to
workout because that's where all the
good stuff happens if you're
overtraining by not sleeping and working
out too frequently you're not gonna see
any results and I have a lot of people I
have one lady she was working out 6
hours a day nothing no results I mean
she's overtraining but when her mind
she's thinking burning off calories but
it wasn't working so we want to play
around with this so in the recovery
phase you got to make sure that your
stress is low you got to make sure
you're sleeping here to make sure you're
not overdoing it you're not eating
incorrect things but a lot of things
food-wise can go into this too like if
you were to eat a little sugar or a
little wine or a little juice you're
going to pretty much kiss that benefit
from workouts out the window for about
48 to 72 hours as well and I'll do
another video on that but the point is
that there are things that can screw it
up hidden carbs a little bit of sugar so
this is um so what we want to do is we
want to shorten a time we want to
increase the intensity but you got to do
it at a very gradual pace because it's
very easy to overdo it and hurt yourself
which I'm guilty of as well I'm like
jump right in and almost an end up with
that you know sprained ankle or
something like that
so we want to do that and then the key
is that let your body recover I like to
do every other day and see if that works
for most people so so those are some
variables but you want to play around
and see what what's best for you
ok and also I have a quiz down below
take the evaluation quiz and this quiz
helps you to find out a lot of other
barriers that you might have that are
stopping you from getting healthy thanks
for watching